يعني هو دائما بصراحه الجزء الاول
ربما احس الناس في مشكله بالتواصل معه
من حيث
السرد الحكائي من حيث عناصر التشويق لكن
بحب اقول لك سواء بالجزء الاول او الجزء
الثاني كل ما قيل عنه هو لا يخرج عن حدود
الانطباع صديقي ليس هناك قراءه نقديه
بالمعنى اللي بيستفيد منها الفنان لكن
الكندوش انا لا اخفي كان يجب ان نراه
موشوريا الامر لان بمعنى انه هو في صيغه
انتاجيه غير مسبوقه عاليه المستوى في جهه
بصري من المخرج بذله حقيقه ملفات وفي
مجموعه من يعني مجموعه من خيره او قسم من
خيره ممثلين سوريا كان الاداء في متوازن
اداء همم في رغبه حقيقيه احنا عملناه هلا
الناس لم تجد فيه على مستوى الحكائي
والسرد وجهه بعض المشاكل بالتالي كان هناك
مكاشف في صريحه تمتدارك الامر في الجزء
الثاني من الكندوش وتم تجاوز كل ما كان
فاترا بين المسلسل وبين المتفرج بس حقيقه
هو تم تناوله الجزء الاول ببعض العثف يعني
ببعض التعجب وبعض يمكن لانه عمل له
بروباجندا كبيره اعلاميه بس هو الحقيقه
واحد من المسلسلات اللي انا بشوفها ان
واحد من المسلسلات
الجزء الاول كان
انا اعترف ان الجزء الثاني
بالضبط بالضبط من الناحيه الحكائيه
والسرديه الجزء الثاني اعتقد انه كان اكثر
تماسكا انما الجزء الاول لا اعتبر انه كان
ضعيف بالمطلق هناك زوايا منه كما قلت لك
يعني على مستوى الاداء على مستوى الانتاج
الملفت على مستوى الشغل البصري الى المخرج
في الحكايه
وفي السرد
اعتقد هو اعتقد هو اصبح هناك
رهان على لحظات لم تفلح يمكن هذه
الريحانات كل الاحوال صديقي العزيز العمل
الفني لا يخرج من قطر المغامره دائما لو
كان اي واحد فينا لديه وصفي محدده لصناعه
مسلسل ناجح بالمطلاق لتحولنا جميعا الى
منتج ليس هناك
المسلسل
مرتبط مرتبط تاثيره بالمزاج العام للناس
بتوقيت العرض صحيح بمحطه العرب الوضع
السياسي والاجتماعي في لحظه عرضه الجانب
الاقتصادي والمزاج الشعبي العام في حاله
يعني هناك كثير من العصر الموضوعيه التي
تتحكم
بطبيعه تلقي مشروع فنيه
وهذا شيء احنا اكيد بنعرفه على تماسي
وبس بكل الاحوال يبقى الفن محاولات يبقى
الفن تجارب وهي كانت شركه قدمت انتاج غير
مسبوق واكملناه الان في مسلسل جديد اسمه
زقاق الجنه انتهينا من تصويره متاخرا
واعتقد انه تجربه
بالسرد الحكائي وعناصر التشويق
للاسف كما احيانا
بيطلب المزاج العام اقول للاسف لانه
احيانا انت بتعمل مشروع في مساحات تامليه
لا تترك اثره همم يعني لذلك لابد من
الاهتمام بالجانب السردي والحكائي